идеальное начало дня которое формирует
весь твой день а вообще и всю твою жизнь
в этом видео я вам расскажу о том как
формировать а начало своего дня как
начинать день для того чтобы он прошёл
успешно и удачно поэтому досмотрите это
видео до конца это очень важно потому
что начало дня формирует то как пройдёт
ваш день а что такое ваша жизнь ваша
жизнь состоит из таких дней таким
образом начав день правильно вы по сути
меняете свою жизнь я уверен каждый из
вас много раз
пытался начинать свою жизнь или менять
начало своего дня не у всех получалось
но я сегодня попытаюсь поделиться с вами
лайфхаками и приёмами которые я сам
применяю в своей жизни и Первое правило
которое необходимо выполнять для того
чтобы ваш день прошёл
хорошо Это не вставать рано это вставать
раньше сразу оговорюсь Если вы встаёте в
6 утра то раньше не надо вставать это
идеальное начало дня но я уверен
большинство из вас которые смотрит это
видео встают позже 6:00 утра поэтому
Первое правило Вставайте Раньше просто
Что делаете Если вы встаёте в 9:00
утра начните вставать 8:45 либо 8:30
проживи с этим неделю-две потом
поставьте будильник ещё на 15 минут или
на 30 минут раньше проживи с этим ещ 2-3
недели постепенно постепенно доведите
это до 6:00 утра Ну можно до 7:00 утра
Но в
идеале любой день надо начинать с 6:00
утра после пробуждения Первое что я
делаю я мысленно находясь ещё в постели
Я представляю картинку предстоящего дня
и я представляю Какие задачи я буду
выполнять с кем я сегодня буду
встречаться почему я это делаю потому
что у меня есть план и Мои встречи как
правило расписаны поэтому Аа я могу
представить себе такую картинку Но даже
если у вас встречи не расписаны и нет
такого чёткого плана попытайтесь в
голове составить план хотя бы В общих
чертах план может быть таким что сегодня
мне нужно сделать вот это Для этого мне
нужно встретиться с этим потом
встретиться с этим а Для этого мне нужно
переговорить Сначала с вот этим и вот
этим То есть грубо Представьте картинку
дня грубо Представьте что в этом дне А
должно и будет происходить настройте
себя на это и сразу позитивно настройте
на это то есть Я встречусь с этим Если
мы с ним об этом договоримся то я сделаю
так если не договоримся Всё равно ничего
страшного но я встречу должна провести
или должен провести с этим человеком как
бы то ни было мне нужно понять его
позицию то есть изначально Вы должны
представить картинку дня и настроить
себя по отношению к этой картинке и это
будет формировать фон на котором вы
будете проживать этот день второе что я
делаю после пробуждения Это я
проговаривая аффирмации кто-то может
назвать это медитации кто-то может
называть это аффирмаций Называйте как
угодно дело не в названии что я обычно
проговаривая я обычно проговаривая в
постели по три раза следующие фразы
первое Я счастлив и доволен жизнью Какая
бы у вас ни была жизнь каждый день
повторяя эту фразу
отношение своей жизни поэтому говорите я
счастлив и доволен жизнь второе Я
благодарен всевышнему Я благодарен
всевышнему очень сильная и важная фраза
третье Всевышний любит и заботится обо
мне это важная фраза которая
будет прикрывать ваши тылы и чтобы вы не
делали в течение дня Вот это ощущение
что Всевышний любит и заботится о вас
оно будет создавать
Дополните степень контроля и Комфорта
четвёртое Я живу в мире изобилия Я живу
в мире изобилия это аффирмация очень
важна для того чтобы снять барьеры и
свои ограничения мы все привыкли думать
что мы живём в условиях дефицита нам всё
время чего-то не хватает мы всё время
проводим жизнь в борьбе за какие-то а
дефицитные ресурсы убеждай себя что вы
живёте в мире изобилия другим же людям
хватает всего Почему этого не может быть
у вас проблема наверное в вашем
поведении а не в недостатке ресурсов в
мире поэтому ресурсов в мире хватает всё
время говорите себе Я живу в мире
изобилия ещё одна сильная аффирмация
каждое утро Говорите себе Мир полон
чудес Мир полон чудес Если вы не будете
допускать что в мире существуют чудеса
то они с вами и не будут случаться А что
такое чудо Чудо - это стечение таких
обстоятельств при котором вы достигаете
своих целей гораздо быстрее и без
приложения усилий вот что такое чудо на
самом деле Например
если что-то случилось то что Вы не
хотели то это вы не называете чудом вы
называете это неприятным сюрпризом или
внезапной проблемой а Чудо - это когда
то что вы хотели вдруг к вам прилетает
Без особых усилий и очень быстро очень
легко вы такие О класс это чудо поэтому
убеждай себя Мир полон чудес Я лично в
это очень сильно верю и у меня в жизни
случалось очень много чудес К сожалению
атеисты думают что их утверждение таково
сначала Покажите мне чуда После этого я
начну верить но это так не работает
работает так сначала поверьте а потом
начнут появляться чудеса Если вы хотите
чтобы вашей жизни было больше чудес
начните верить ните верить во Всевышнего
начните верить в то что Мир полон чудес
и шестая аффирмация я выбираю провести
этот день радостно Дело в том что с вами
в течение дня могут случаться любые
события как позитивные так и негативные
Вопрос не в событиях события сами по
себе нейтральные вопрос в вашем
отношении к этим событиям И когда вы
утром себе проговаривает и говорите я
выбираю провести этот день Радостно и
если с вами в этот день происходит
какое-то негативное собы Вы вспоминаете
то о чём вы говорили Вы же сегодня
сделали выбор что проведёте этот день
радостно независимо от событий и вы
таким образом восстанавливается своё
Душевное равновесие после того
как я
пробуждают часть где я молюсь и я
опускаю также гигиенические процедуры Я
обязательно делаю какую-то прогулку
ходьбу Ну вы делаете минимум 30 минут 30
минут походите Выйдите на улицу походите
погуляйте освежите вот этот свежий
воздух утренний воздух он вас сильно
взбодрит и даст
такой энергичный настрой дня Во время
этих прогулок обязательно размышляйте о
повышении своей эффективности совместите
эту прогулку с размышлением о том как
мне повысить свою эффективность Что мне
сделать чтобы делать то что я каждый
день делаю проще
эффективнее И не с такими затратами
усили и так далее после этого или даже
во время прогулки Вы можете реакту Зро
свои планы сделать ревизию своих целей
Подумайте к чему вы стремитесь подумайте
Что вы хотите добиться и актуальны ли
ваши планы каждый день Думайте о своём
будущем и о своих планах Ну естественно
после этого вам нужно здоровый завтрак и
поехать на работу Вот с этого момента Вы
готовы К любым ситуациям которые могут
возникнуть А в течение вашего рабочего
дня поэтому утренний Старт начало дня
имеет решающее значение представьте себе
такую ситуацию что вы заводите
автомобиль и сразу же не разогрев его
начинаете гонять на бешеной скорости что
будет вы просто угробить двигатель вы
угробить автомобиль любое событие любое
действие любой процесс требует в начале
начального разогрева мы не можем сходу
Вруби не можем сходу выполнять действия
эффективно нам обязательно нужно
так и ваш рабочий день требует того
чтобы вы аккуратно и правильно его
начали и ещё раз подчеркну начало
рабочего дня формирует то как вы
проведёте день вся ваша жизнь состоит из
таких дней соответственно каждое утро
задавая себе правильный Настрой на весь
день Вы меняете свою жизнь кто-то
послушав мои рекомендации скажет да Но
это же занимает уйму времени Ну
во-первых это неправда Давайте пройдёмся
по всем пунктам когда я сказал Вставайте
не рано А Вставайте Раньше хотя бы на
полчаса этим самым вы уже выиграли
полчаса что можно за это время сделать
представить картинку дня максимум займёт
5-10 минут проговорить аффирмации
максимум ещё 10 минут вот у вас 20 минут
ушло прогулка на улице 30 минут у вас
ушло 50 минут во время прогулки вы
размышляете о своей эффективности и
можете делать ревизию планов это всё
входит в эти же 30 минут а дальше
завтрак Ну завтрак может занять ещё 20
минут Вот 50 плю 20 - это 70 минут и всё
Дальше дорога до работы по сути всё это
можно уложить минимум в час Ну а лучше
всего в 3 часа в идеале вот я это делаю
Вот это всё за 3 часа потому что я гуляю
по полтора часа я размышляю у меня час
каден планирования и так далее но в
вашем случае одного часа будет
достаточно так вот начните с того что
вставать на полчаса раньше через 2
недели либо через месяц Вставайте ещё на
полчаса раньше и всё у вас уже есть
время для проведения всех этих процедур
Наверняка у каждого из вас есть
определённые тоже ритуалы или и рутины
которые вы делаете по утрам Я не говорю
про гигиенические процедуры чистку зубов
и так далее это делают все И это не
обсуждаемого про другие ритуалы которая
формирует весь ваш день обязательно
кстати Напишите в комментариях и те у
кого есть ритуалы утренние и те у кого
нету но тех у кого нету Попробуйте
внедрить те инструменты которые я
сегодня вам сказал и поживи с этим хотя
бы неделю либо месяц и просто посмотрите
на изменение своей жизни на изменение
своего самочувствия на изменение своего
настроения и то как вы чувствуете себя в
течение дня я уверен это очень
благожелательно скажется на том как вы
проживаете каждый день